interior office shows a whiteboard
filled with scientific formulas a man
with glasses a flannel shirt and wearing
a build cap is seated at a computer
workstation early in my life i wanted to
be a paleontologist
and that's what actually led me to
molecular biology lrvan dyer phd senior
investigator computational biology
branch in cbi at one level i could say
that i wish to understand the whole
protein universe animation of rotating
3d protein clusters proteins can be
divided into
evolutionary units is a part of a
protein which is preserved over
evolution because natural selection is
maintaining that part for some reason
and one realization which dawned on us
starting around the early 90s and this
was a very profound realization for all
of biology is that there is a relatively
small number of these evolutionary units
of proteins which we term domains
which constitutes the entire protein
universe of all organisms across the
tree of life
if we can understand the functions of
these units then that goes a long way
towards understanding what organisms do
views buyer working at his computer
workstation and given that there are
many gaps in our understanding of what
organisms do
one way to get at it is to first find
all these domains
the second aspect of it is predicting
functions for them the first phase of my
research we captured most of the low
hanging fruit which were the big
families conserved across all organisms
now we are moving on to the more
difficult terrain but the difficult
terrain also holds a lot of promise
because
many understood functions are hiding
within that difficult terrain and it
gives these offshoots in the form of
biotechnological reagents parts of a dna
strand text crispr case nine there are
things like restriction enzymes the
crispr systems and dna modification
systems all of these have become very
popular reagents
nlm is a world leader in the analysis of
protein sequences protein structures and
inferring evolution from these bits of
information and this has been a very
long-standing interest of mine so this
is the place to be
text dr iyer is deciphering the language
of life written in dna rna and protein
sequences
for more nlm research visit nlm.nih.gov
research
the gray and blue nlm logo with blue
text serving scientists and society